let's bring dan up let's just start here
i'm gonna give him the opportunity to
roast me fine
dan what's up man
how you been i'm great tapiro is that
how i say it
that's how you say it you said it
correctly many times before so i don't
know what what got into you i said his
name wrong one time and as soon as i get
on zoom he starts roasting me for saying
they're wrong well look i i know you
have problems with with names ending in
o but uh you know this is an easy one i
hear you i hear you how are you
good good i mean i've been busy as can
be uh
you know we've sort of had even limited
uh interactions it's just been a
whirlwind the last four or five months
and
i've been off twitter
um
i mean on but not as much as before and
you know not as uh you know
deeply ingrained in sort of the the
markets um you know as we built out the
uh
the holdings of 10t
talk to us about 10t and what the kind
of original idea was and then walk us
through uh this 750 million dollar
fundraiser across the various vehicles
yeah um you know the idea originally was
to build a
broad sort of macro sector exposure
um to the digita to the growth in the
digital asset ecosystem so you know as
you know i'm a
pretty hardcore bitcoiner but i also
think there is a world where there are
lots of things growing up in the overall
ecosystem lots of great businesses uh
that have grown up and you know i'm not
my background is not as a venture
capitalist so i don't have a specialty
in you know
trying to figure out you know which code
is better and you know which chain is
going to work for whatever it is and so
i said to myself look i there's a
there's a lot going on in this um
in the private equity
uh world in the digital asset ecosystem
there are a lot of companies that are a
lot larger than people understand and
you know i'd like to get that kind of
exposure for my own uh personal
portfolio and dtap capital and so
um went about the idea of constructing
this portfolio of 10 to 15
businesses operating in the space again
not involved with the cryptocurrencies
or you know the protocols or tokens or
anything else except for
the equity in these businesses and i did
that largely because um i wanted i
wanted to build something that was very
easy for outsiders to understand for
you know as we say people in the legacy
world or the boomer crowd or just people
over 50 who have a really hard time
uh understanding what's going on here
and are not comfortable
uh with direct exposure in the
underlying cryptocurrencies especially
you know i think the volatility
um is a problem and also
uh you know what are the exact
fundamentals that are driving these
things and it's just it's just a lot to
comprehend you know if you've had
success and you've been in the
traditional investment world for 30
years it's just not that easy to make a
transition and so i i said listen i'm
building this portfolio for myself and
this is how i would like it um to look
um
and we just went out built a team went
out
and spoke to people in my network and
friends of mine and people from my
background and said look this is this is
what the portfolio broadly is going to
look like and what we did is we broke it
down
into three buckets there's digital asset
ecosystem gateways next gen financial
services businesses and blockchain
infrastructure companies and basically
we have three to four uh companies in
each bucket
and the idea really is to hold them for
five six seven years
and i think we're going to get multiples
appreciation you saw in the press
release some of the businesses that
we've all that we all already own and i
i know you're familiar with all of them
and you're an investor yourself and
actually a few of them
um
talk to me about when you went out to
raise the money so you've got a very
unique position in that uh for 25 years
you've invested across markets you've
started previous businesses before uh in
different sectors uh you've worked with
or for
some of the best global macro investors
in the world um and so you've got kind
of a very unique uh network and and the
trust of a lot of people and you've done
great work with with a bunch of people
that are well respected in traditional
finance when you went out to have those
conversations what was the reaction from
whether it was you know the billionaire
friends or from uh these like
institutional allocators
yeah i mean
it's funny
it it i always say this it sort of broke
down like almost
you know according to age uh
you know if i met somebody who was an
investor let's say in their 30s they
were super interested but you know
usually writing smaller
checks and
you know
meeting guys sort of in their 60s or
later very tough sell
um but of course you know they're
um you know they're managing most of the
money so it's sort of we have a nice
cross-section yes a lot of guys from my
background uh all the lps more or less
or our friends or people from my network
as you said
i think people
um i
i i think people who were interested in
the space
but just didn't have exposure and we're
looking for ways to get exposure
um those are the people who really
were excited by the idea because look
the investment team and i we write these
50 page investment memos that take weeks
if not months sometimes
um behind each of the investments and so
i can say listen the fund is putting in
uh and this is how we really got to the
750 you know i would say the fund itself
which is around 390 million you know the
fund is investing let's say 40 million
dollars into this business and then i
would say
you know here's our research this is why
and you know
there's co-invest if you're interested
and so what's happened is because quite
a few of the lps are from the money
management business they're either
retired or still in the game they they
read the 50-page investment memo and
then they you know they make a decision
for themselves
and so you know in some cases you have
guys who you know put let's say a
million dollars into the fund but then
all of a sudden they're asking for
five million of co-invest or 10 million
um it's because they they have quite a
lot of firepower
and
you know i think they're happy
uh to have the general exposure in the
fun but they're also experienced enough
to want to really leverage up when they
see the opportunity and
you know i would say the skill we have
really isn't explaining something very
clearly and you know i that that's sort
of the one skill that i developed
uh over 25 years uh not only you know
managing my own portfolio and portfolios
you know at the funds where i worked at
but you know
always sort of being very working very
closely with the head of those funds and
being able to explain yourself clearly
simply
um you know and to be able to explain a
subject that is foreign
um
you know and and to put it in terms that
people will understand
i think has been the reason why
we've grown so quickly and it's sort of
way beyond my expectations
um because the co-invest uh vehicles all
add up to about another
you know call it 300 million or so so
uh actually i think it's it's actually
more it's i think it's closer to 350
uh in in co-invest vehicles and i don't
think we you know we've allocated about
remarkably 80 of the fund money and
again we really just launched at the end
of january
so i mean it's been as i said drinking
from a fire hose
when you think about the um i'll just
call them kind of billionaire wall
street asset management crowd uh and the
institutional investor crowd i think
that you guys had a uh a public pension
also participate that was publicly named
talk to me about the difference in
conversations between the individuals
that yes they are very wealthy yes they
operate in some form or fashion like an
institution to some degree but the
institutions that you actually have
participating what was the difference in
conversation there
yeah i mean it's sort of interesting um
yeah i think it was it was released in
the bloomberg article it is state of
michigan their pension fund
uh merce they
uh they invested a considerable amount
and i think they were looking for a way
to get exposure
um
you know i don't think they own uh
bitcoin or can and
but you know they're smart people they
wanted to get exposure to the sector
broadly
but weren't really interested in taking
on the risk of early stage investments
and you know the minimum size and
market value of companies we look at is
500 but of the 11 businesses we we own
um
you know only two
nine of them are over a billion dollars
in market valuation only two are sort of
between 500 and a billion and so
you know they didn't
you know those types of businesses are
also de-risked
um they don't have the same type of
business risk look they're not going to
go up a hundred x like uh solana or you
know some of these other things that
have moved uh 100 200 x or whatever it
is you know we we think some of the
businesses can go up five to ten times
in the next uh five six seven eight
years
and for a big fun like that um
you know they can put a lot of money to
work in bigger names
um but it also helped that a very close
friend of mine
um had
um taken an investment from them a
friend of mine about 15 years
um you know knew them very very well
and he of course spoke on our behalf um
to them i did not reach out to them i
didn't know them beforehand
um
but honestly i was told that um you know
they turned around within a few weeks to
make the investment
uh i was told that like never before as
a pension fund turned around that
quickly i i don't i'm not you know i
i've never really raised a lot of money
um i'd always worked for funds that had
more capital than they knew what to do
with so
i was never on any sort of fundraising
circuit
uh you know where i met pension funds or
whatever it was so it was really again
as i described before there are
institutional players out there from the
legacy world they just don't know how to
access it and play it in a way that
they're comfortable with and so the fund
is somewhat structured you know based on
my own personal parameters what i wanted
for my own
portfolio but also you know with
you know
keeping in mind of course what other
institutional type you know um and you
know
more institutional type investors uh
want and are comfortable with we also
have a a foundation uh an la based
foundation
but you know they're you know multiple
billion dollar
foundation but they're very uh savvy
they you know they've been long actually
bitcoin i think and ethereum for quite a
while
and they have a few venture investments
but just not
it's just there's too much risk there
they don't you know they don't want a
black or red option and i think that
that which just means that you know the
typical vc i guess you know makes ten
investments and nine go to zero and and
and one ends up being google
and the fund returns you know a zillion
percent
it's sort of i don't know i'm sort of
uncomfortable with that strategy even
though it's worked brilliantly and in
this space the vcs have had huge returns
um but there's only so much an investor
can have even if he likes that strategy
in a vc bucket
and so um
you know 10t
which only invests in the mid to late
stage companies in the space
uh is sort of a as i call it more of a
broad sector bet uh you could call it uh
like in a sense you can think of us as
building an index of the future i mean i
think if you look at the companies we
bought i think
look within five years most of them will
probably be public
um you know some of them could be in the
s p 500
uh you know if they weren't in crypto
you know some of them are making
hundreds of millions of dollars in
revenue they'd already be public and in
the s p so
um
but i think that's a little bit of an
advantage for us
that the growth equity guys who would
normally
play in this space
um you know except for you know the
tigers and co2s and they'll come in and
write one-off checks and you know they
can do whatever they like but
most of the growth equity space they're
not that comfortable with currency or
with macro
and this really is a macro bet and we're
using the private equity structure
to take a long-term view
because i think the one thing that kills
you in this space
is you know the short-term view i think
no one knows what's gonna happen on a
three-month or five-month view or even
necessarily on a one-year view but
on a five-year view three to five years
we have a very uh high degree of
conviction
and as you know i mean since we started
talking almost two years ago
um you know in the middle of 19
i've had a very strong view about how
this world was developing and where
bitcoin prices were headed
um you know and i remember that that uh
that interview we did about gold and
bitcoin
um
you know i think
uh you know i still am a believer in
physical gold and that's a conversation
for another day
um i've got lots of exposures in my
portfolio i know pomp i know you're 100
long bitcoin in your portfolio but for
us you know guys a little bit older
we're not quite a 100 percent um you
know and and try to have a few different
types of exposures
um
but um you know i think that this is a
differentiated enough
expression
of an investment
of view
that it is attractive um you know for
that institutional but but who's
interested right the guys who say to me
there were many guys who just said it's
ponzi we don't believe in this no thank
you and i was like okay it was very easy
conversations because we were rejected
right away
uh or
they had been thinking about it right
and so those people we try to help and
we try to educate and we give them
things to read
uh we send them some of your podcasts
believe it or not
um you know so
you know as you know there's a lot of
educating to do in the space
when you think about bitcoin let's start
there uh where do you think bitcoin goes
from a price standpoint this year are
you a believer in this like super cycle
theory are you more a believer that you
know we kind of just go sideways how do
you think about bitcoin through the end
of the year
well you know i just said it's almost
pointless to have a three to four month
view but i know that's what you know
sort of people look at it look i was in
the hedge fund business and i had marks
every day and every week and
liquidity every month i mean i lived
that for you know 25 years you said i
just think that you know this is an
asset that's returned 250 annualized
over the last 11 years it's the greatest
return of any asset in the history of
the world i mean probably going back to
caveman times um so
i
don't think i mean i really am a hobbler
i don't think you mess around with that
i i always thought and i've said
probably even a year ago i think that we
we're going to get to around a trillion
dollar market valuation and then we
would consolidate
and that's sort of what we've done i
mean in my world view
40 000 bitcoin 50 000 600 it's all
basically around the same price
um
i think we could still get to 100
uh by the end of the year i
you know we might need some macro things
to happen i think that's more likely
sort of within six to 12 months
um but
you know and i think i've said this on
our last interview and even two years
ago that three four five hundred
thousand which would put the market
value at call it you know five six
trillion dollars that was the first stop
for me
um you know and i just simply
you know i've talked about this a lot
but it just in my mind
i think okay bitcoin you know the most
decentralized most secure network in the
history of the world the potential sort
of value protocol for the entire
internet okay
and it's worth a trillion dollars which
is roughly half of amazon which is just
one company
so
to me
i look and i think you know how much
would it cost even a company to to try
to build the bitcoin network from
scratch i mean it's trillions and
trillions of dollars so you know five
trillion dollar market value is a is a
comfortable estimate that i am very
comfortable with in fact i called the
fund we called the fund 10t now 10t
stands for 10 trillion and what is that
well the market value okay when we
started thinking about this idea in 19
and 20
i said the value of bitcoin ethereum all
the cryptocurrency and all the equity
in the space okay was around 300 billion
and i said well
i think we can go from 300 billion to 10
trillion in 10 years and so that's sort
of our mantra 10 t in 10 years but the
problem is where it's 3 trillion now
so like we're a chip shot away from 10
trillion in 10 years i mean we we just
launched really in in january
and
we're already at 3t
so
you know the biggest mistake i've made
with all of this my the was i've
underestimated the
exponentiality of the growth in the
space
um it just it's it's sort of not
anything that the mind can comprehend
and last thing i'd say on this though is
that what i was just looking at the
teaser for the fun that we wrote a year
ago
there were 20 businesses that we
identified with over a billion dollar
market valuation
today there are 70.
just think about that
70 businesses
it's crazy to see there's a lot to do in
this space and
i presume i'll have you know there'll be
other people getting involved i mean
soon
when you think about uh the businesses
is it fair to say that your investment
strategy is essentially to invest in the
infrastructure uh and then your benefit
you're benefiting from like the overall
industry growth and the kind of that
index approaches you're basically
betting hey the industry is going to be
you know much larger hundreds of percent
larger uh in the future
and you want to bet on businesses that
are going to win as long as the industry
grows is that kind of a fair
characterization that's that's exactly
right um
you know that's exactly right i
i think uh you know we want to pay a
reasonable uh multiple of revenue and
and earnings as well
um i mean i don't think there's a
company that we paid more than 10 times
revenue for
um you know we're we're there there are
so many opportunities out there we're
very active in the secondary market as
well we speak to companies directly um
you know i i'm not really willing to pay
25 or 30 times revenue
um and there are great companies that we
just passed on
um that will grow a lot
just because
you know we don't have to buy everything
there there are lots of of great
companies but
um yeah i would say these are companies
that we think are core to the ecosystem
and you know the approach really was
it's a 300 billion dollar
in you know late 1920 300 300 billion
dollar world
and we think it's going to 10 trillion
and so that's 30x and if it goes 3dx if
we have a basket uh portfolio
uh diversified nicely of you know sort
of broadly what you're calling picks and
shovels businesses that are constructing
you know the rails of this new digital
asset ecosystem
you know the odds are the portfolio is
going to go up and
i we don't need a 30x to be happy
um but we actually put that 10 t
obviously you know we're putting our our
uh you know we're eating our own cooking
on this one i mean i put it in the title
of the fun so
um
you know a portfolio
i think broadly is going to have such
wind at its back that it should do well
and again you can see from the names
that we purchased
um
that you know it is it is uh diversified
into those buckets and then these
businesses broadly do different types of
things so talk to me about um the
biggest surprise as you've been
deploying the capital i know you've
deployed a very large portion of the 750
million dollars already uh what's been
the biggest surprise to you whether it's
you know as you've dug deeper into the
companies talking to entrepreneurs
talking to investors
what surprised you
well
let me see i mean i guess i would say
that you know one of the hesitations
that many people we spoke with initially
had was they said well dan that's great
your team is great you know everyone has
connections in the network in the space
but how are you going to procure these
blocks of stock you know um you know i
had the portfolio more or less broadly
uh outlined before we launched i said to
investors you know this is what i'm
interested in
you know we had five leaders and five
backups and i said
broadly within these you know for the
three buckets within these 30 companies
you know we're going to have a portfolio
and
you know hopefully we'll get you know
some of our leaders uh we won't have to
go to our backups but this is what it's
going to look like and almost every
person said well how are you going to do
that how you get maybe the stock's not
available etc etc biggest surprise
is that it's been very easy
to source
uh the the equity in the businesses that
we wanted very easy versus expectations
and um
you know and i think that's why the lps
also keep asking for you know when is
the next fun we allocated very quickly
much more quickly than we thought but
again at reasonable valuations we
weren't reaching for the moon or
anything we just we said
you know these are the types of
businesses we're interested in you know
we approached a lot of the companies
directly we had you know have built good
relationships um you know i think we're
still the only fund
i think out there that is focused
exclusively and only on mid to late
stage uh companies in the digital asset
ecosystem so
you know and i think people in the space
know that um
and so it's not
you know as you know it's a very flat
space uh you can reach out to someone on
twitter um it's not it's not that that
hard
um and if people feel that you know you
are bringing new
capital to the space and i think we are
i think we're bringing you know people
joke with me that oh dan you know you're
doing you're doing crypto for boomers i
mean it's sort of true um you know we're
bringing like completely new capital to
the space and we're allocating it i
think to some of the smartest guys and
i'm saying to myself these guys they
know what to do with it they're much
smarter than i am
uh in certainly on the weeds you know
getting deep into the weeds
and they're going to be able to pivot to
where the action is to where the
business is to the places that really
need capital so i'm in a sense
really you know i think some of these
businesses already are budding
conglomerates and also in a way like vc
funds as well because
you know some of the businesses they're
snapping up these smaller companies
and they're incorporating them into
their operating businesses so
you know in a way
they know
what smaller companies are going to be
successful almost better than the vcs
because they're incorporating them into
their bigger businesses so
um
i would say the biggest surprise was
that we haven't had difficulty and also
in the future i mean there are a lot of
companies out there i mean there's quite
a long pipeline of companies that have
approached us or that we've marked um
you know that are that we think are
interesting and worth investing in
when you think about um
the industry at large one of the things
that comes up a lot is regulation
obviously we're seeing it in all
different forms and fashion some of it
seems to be a tailwind some of it seems
to be a headwind how do you talk to
legacy um kind of market investors
people who think about regulation a lot
want uh to understand that there's
certainty from a regulation standpoint
what are those conversations about
yeah i think
the one thing that i try to you know
make very clear to the lps
is that crypto
is a
you know is a global business
bitcoin ethereum it's global all the the
things popping up in the ecosystem it's
global and if you look at total world
volume
uh spot and futures i think the us is 10
of world volume so i keep telling people
listen stop telling me about the sec and
the treasury and all this stuff i get it
yeah the us is going slow
they're putting speed bumps out there i
personally am not so sure they they know
what they're doing
um they'll figure it out uh they'll
figure it out but
for the investments that we're making
they're all global businesses
and some of them are us but we have some
you know we have a non-regulated
business in there but he's buttoned up
he's smart he's not doing any he's doing
his kyc we're not you know concerned um
about like any
issues it's just that he doesn't operate
in the united states and that's fine
again people in the u.s think everything
is always just about the u.s and in the
last 30 40 years and before
really since the war i guess that's been
true
um
but
you know
this may be the first time that from a
technology innovation and financial
innovation perspective the us is
definitely not in the lead
and it could be you know i think that
this is an opportunity i've been saying
this for two years
for the legislators here for people in
government
dig deep understand what's going on here
and my goodness i mean incentivize
innovation forget about like over
regulating it and being difficult and
clamping down and all of this stuff
um this is the future and we don't want
to be left behind
and you know i tell my lps these are
these companies they're diversified
globally
um you know even the us ones so
i just
you know i i think it takes a little bit
of time for people to understand that um
i mean just think about how many you
know there are probably node operators
in every country that exists in the
world right
of course you can't say that about other
assets
of course
i've got my brother john here he's got a
couple questions for you
yeah hey dan thank you for doing this
it's really nice to meet you um 10t is
an awesome name by the way 10t holdings
i love that uh it's only awesome if
we're right
that is true that is true um so i'm
curious about you were talking about
investing in the infrastructure of kind
of the digital asset economy what
excites you the most about that so i've
seen that you guys have done investments
into kraken ledger sas um like what is
exciting to you about that is it the
lightning network is it the hardware is
it kind of the um the exchanges like
what are you excited about moving
forward
yeah i mean you know i take a little bit
of a pedestrian uh approach to it in the
sense that
you know what excites me about the
businesses we're buying
is the fact that they're making a lot of
money
right i'm an investor
okay and the guys who are winning and
know how to win and know how to build
businesses
um those are the guys i want to invest
in that's different from you know
projects that i think are cool
that i think could work
um again i'm not a venture capitalist i
i don't have the ability to
make skilled judgments about you know
these budding enterprises um you know
in a sense
you know i'm letting
in a way i'm not letting but i'm i'm not
making these investments at c or in the
a rounds
uh or really even b i mean we're usually
focused on b plus and c and d
uh i don't mind paying a higher
valuation
um you know a higher market valuation
if the company has established itself
already um
you know because
the space is growing so quickly
um
i i just as i said i'm just trying to
build a broad diversified
um bet for
um you know for the traditional investor
and i'll tell you you look at the list
of companies for rlp base i mean most of
them have never heard of these
businesses before so just think about
that never
and
so that's why i say i think we've we've
tapped into a a whole new
uh type of investor base
um
yeah
and i mean so i again
the the criteria really is this
threshold
um you know do they have a
you know are they are it's not not a
business looking for a business right
it's a business that's already
established itself and is dominant in
its space
dan when you think about uh moving
forward are you going to just continue
to
allocate capital to the space uh do you
think it's something where once you get
the money invested then you'll kind of
sit and harvest it how do you think
about kind of future plans
yeah i mean i think look if there are
opportunities out there reasonable
evaluations i think we'll keep going in
in some form or another i mean
um you know if i if i look out and there
aren't
opportunities or everything is trading
at 30 40 times revenue then i think that
would you know we take we take a rest um
but as i said i mean just think about it
one year ago
20 businesses worth over a billion
dollars today there are 70 and that's
not that's not just multiple expansion
and in some cases you know that's
massive revenue expansion
and so you know just
in very like simple terms i mean we all
know the volume just the volume at the
exchanges is up 5x from last year i mean
that's 500 percent
and so there are huge knock-on effects
as the number of wallets increase as
adoption increases
um it's really it's it's exponential and
so as long as there are opportunities
out there i think we'll continue to
allocate capital i think that uh that
makes sense where can we send people to
find you on twitter or find more
information about what you're doing
well i'm dtap cap on twitter
um but you know we have a website 10t
fund you know if you just punch it into
google as i
you know you get to our website and
um you know we have all sorts of
information there um
i think we may even have our
the uh interview that you and i did last
on there uh under the educational
section but you know that's a good place
that's a good place to go the website i
love it i love it listen you uh you've
been ahead of the curve you continued to
uh
to surprise to the upside just like
bitcoin and everything else so uh keep
it up i think this is uh awesome and
then obviously the portfolio that you
guys have built is a list of very
impressive names so i think that any
founder who uh who has the opportunity
to partner with you guys is uh is pretty
intelligent if they go ahead and they
pursue that
well thanks pop and i i hope that some
of your early stage investments
uh grow into you know 10 t investments
so i'm looking forward to us doing some
business as well maybe down the line i'm
going to send them all to you like
listen dan is the smartest guy that i
know go ahead and take all of his money
all right
anyway thank you very much for having me
really enjoyed this absolutely thanks so
much for doing it everyone make sure
that you go check out
10tfund.com where you can go follow dan
on twitter at d tap cap
all capitalized by the way which is uh
is my favorite thing about your twitter
um all right sir thank you so much
thanks all right bye
hey guys bang bang thanks so much for
watching the best business show today
and don't forget to check out our
partner sofi they make all this possible
they're a super app that lets you save
spend borrow earn and invest all from
one single platform and if you go there
today and you sign up for a sofi invest
account you can get between five dollars
and a thousand bucks for free from sofi
not everyone's obviously gonna get a
thousand dollars but everyone gets
something don't say that i never did
anything for you go check them out at
sofi.com
download the app and go ahead and open
an account sofi.com pomp and make sure
you come back and watch more of the best
business show we're going to build the
biggest business show in the world and
we need your help
[Music]